We're taking calls via discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord.
Let's briefly go to my friend Pedro from Colombia.
Pedro with us.
Ole, ole, ole Miss, Pacman, can you hear me
see my Tamiami Austronesian, Mr Pacman.
Good to talk to Unblessed Siembra is or Mr
Pacman.
Did you see the Mr Biden who finally won CPAC?
See.
I know.
Yeah, I thought he won like a month ago.
I guess he won again.
He's won seven or eight times now.
Yeah.
I don't understand.
Your American system of voting is kind of
confusing.
Yeah.
But I'm happy you know that he finally won
again.
So we went Pedro.
Yeah.
So, uh, you know, Mr Pacman, you know, I don't
really have much to say.
I was thinking of starting on only funds,
you know, but, uh, my wife, you know, I think
if she found out, she might be a little a
little mad.
You know, I wasn't going to post too many,
you know, racy pictures, you know.
But, you know, I just I got like some I got
a nice body, you know, I want to use it for
my advantage.
Pedro, come on.
Come on.
That was taken into account.
Alexian.
Parisa.
Oh, Miss Foster, she's she's doing good.
You know, she she didn't really care who won,
you know.
Well, she kind of like Joe Biden more.
She thinks Trump's a little racist, you know,
but it was a him plaza.
The she's they can see I think he does understand
Spanish, at least it's very interesting.
Um, yeah, that's an interesting conversation
to have someone with a.
She doesn't like me to tell her name, you
know.
I just called my wife in and do you have kids,
Pedra?
Oh, yeah, Perito, he's my my pride and joy,
and I love my little Perito, you know, my
wife, she doesn't think I care about Pellerito
and she always gets me out of the house, you
know, really.
She's like, compañero, you're not doing anything
in me, me, me, me.
But I do care about him.
You Wintersun inability to.
Oh, he's I think he's four years.
Thank you.
All right, Pedro, thank you so much for the
call, OK?
Good to talk to you, Mr. Pakman.
I love your show.
Pleasure.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
I don't know that we'll ever really figure
that out.
I mean, it's I go back and forth as to what
that is, and it's never, never totally clear.
OK, let's take a very quick break.
If you're holding on to talk to me.
Don't go anywhere because we will be back
right to the phones momentarily.